- How do you perform when
you're on your period?
(laughing)
(electric guitar music)
- Hi, my name is Ava Mystic,
and I'm a cam model.
- Hi, my name is Nikita Banks,
and I'm a cam model,
and today we'll be answering questions
that you've always had about camming.
What is the most unique prop
or costume you've used on camera?
- My gadgets, like the
toys I use on camera.
- Oh, vampire costume.
- There's one toy where the
person on the other side
of the camera can control
the toy, so it's awesome.
- Does your family know what you do?
- At this moment my family does know,
but at the beginning when I
started like four years ago,
I was kind of afraid of their reaction.
- Inevitably I had to have
this conversation with my parents.
- When I told my mom
she was pretty shocked,
but she didn't shun me or anything,
and we got over it,
and it's all good now.
- Have you ever become
attracted to a client?
- Yes, yes.
- I have become attracted
to a client before.
- Not just one.
More.
- I really discovered some members
there that are extremely smart and wise.
So yes, I was attracted with more like,
it's first the mind.
The way they talk.
- It never goes further than online.
- It doesn't go any further
because we kind of know
what it's all about.
- How do you perform when
you're on your period?
(laughing)
- What a question.
- I did not expect they did this.
- I prefer to not to
perform or to go online
when I am on my period.
- We have a whole week to get
to know each other
without getting intimate.
- If you are smart enough,
there are other ways than being nude
in order to attract someone,
and you can always use your voice,
your smile, your eyes.
- What is the most money
you've made in one session?
$1,200.00.
- $1,400.00.
- Around $1,000.00 or something like that.
- What are some dirty
talk tips you can give?
- Think outside the box.
- You have to be more open
to your significant other
about your desires, about
your hidden fetishes.
- Some of my favorite lines
are why don't you come over here,
and let me drain your balls?
- Just I will (beep) this open.
(laughing)
- In any case, be open.
- What is the hardest
part of being a cam model?
- There are a lot of guys
just calling us names
because we do this job, and even the guys
that visit those kind of sites.
They're calling us names,
they're treating us not so good.
So I think keep our heads
up is probably the hardest.
- The hardest part, but at
the same time the funnest
I guess is dealing with the
different people and fetishes.
I think that's the hardest part
just because it can be kind of draining.
At the same time though, as
it being the hardest part
I think it's one of the best parts
because you get to just see all types
of avenues of different things and people.
- Do you have any plans to
change careers in the future?
- I think that when you
start to be a cam model,
it's like you have to have some goals,
because it's very easy to earn money,
so I think you should do
something wise with your money
and invest in something,
because you cannot be all
your life a cam model.
- I would love to have
a house in mountains
and like to make it a cabin
or to check in tourists.
- I'm already in the mist of trying
to become a sex therapist,
which is kind of in the same realm.
I think this kind of
gives me kudos to move on
and do that along with
of course my schooling.
- I would say that this
job changed me a lot.
Before I was starting I was really shy.
I could never have the
balls to say like this
to dominate the men or things like that.
I was extremely shy.
- Being as a model can be very creative,
very entertaining, very fun.
It's how you are, you
get to express yourself
in front of thousand of people.
- I discovered many things about myself.
I never knew that I can be sensual.
- Come, see us have fun, talk, whatever.
(sensual bass music)